as humans you know um we derive really
from aliens you know like aliens and
ufos like i'm telling you bro
uh you know it's different from
astrology and [ __ ] bro you know but
like bro life is interesting bro i'm
like
what's up you're funny bro like
i mean [ __ ] don't laugh you know but
you know it's fine
so today's topic we're going to be doing
a different video uh i had a
conversation with somebody
and basically the topic was astrology is
uh prejudice and somebody came on and it
was an interesting conversation
so i figured i would show preach what
happened okay what's the difference
really
between it's like saying for example
okay you americans you're all like so
larger than life
yeah you know like compared to us brits
you know we're a bit like more
um you can you can make generalizations
i made the claim that astrology is
inherently prejudiced right and the
reason being is
even when you gather all the top
astrologers in the world the people who
are the best the best
they did a study double blind and they
found it to be a bunch of horseshit so
it's unreliable
they couldn't have any consistency
whatsoever
so i said the tool itself is
unpredictable for
you know determining people's
personality traits or even predicting
them in any
kind of way so if it's unpredictable and
it's unreliable
and you use that to make an inferred
judgment on somebody
that is prejudicial right because you're
using faulty logic and faulty reason
to determine who someone is before
having any real knowledge of who they
are
now she's saying you know in all
fairness to her
this is a fun stream people were having
great conversations changing their mind
so
no no no heart feeling story but she's
making the claim that
what's wrong with generalizations
generalizations are okay eight
generalizations about different
people from different places i'm not
saying this to triggy or like be
and make it i'm just making a point here
you know where people
you can you can observe that different
people from different places have
different
generally have different characteristics
that doesn't mean it applies to every
single person from that place
that doesn't mean that every single
person from america is like an extrovert
at all it doesn't mean that at all but
you can you can see a pattern
there's nothing really hard i'll give
you an example
i i used to i used to live in a
dangerous neighborhood in los angeles
and black folks over there committed a
lot of crime so after that i was like
okay well black people are
more predominantly prone to being
criminals yeah
so is there anything well i mean are you
making fun of me now because i'm
agreeing with you
sorry am i racist now i'm sorry
are you trying to trick me up on purpose
oh my god oh my god
that was crazy what what you pissed
you pisces of [ __ ] see what i did there
pisces oh man
you pisces of [ __ ] you just tricked her
into saying that am i racist now what
guess what darling a bit yeah a wee bit
just saying that just admit it into that
it's just oh wow
oh wow that's prejudice guys that's
prejudice that's prejudice that's
exactly that because you just
well you you [ __ ] up you just you
proved the point
there is no link between skin color and
criminality
okay when you control for all the
factors when you control for
socioeconomic background when you
control for
uh environment when you control for all
these things studies have already come
out to say
there is no link between race and crime
okay
so when you make that link you said i
observed a black person
10 black people doing this therefore the
color of their skin must have a
correlation
that is faulty logic that is prejudicial
right because you didn't take into
consideration maybe they're from a
really poor area
because if i go to different parts of
the world where there's really poor
white people or asians
you might find replications of those
behaviors but you also have to study the
cultural norms
you have to study like education all
these things and try to see
what is the highest predicting factor
for this and then see if it's a
causation issue or if it's just a
correlation
right because you can make really bad
inferences and this could hold people
back if you
if you live with these ideas right it's
like going to the crime scene and being
like okay we got the suspect
yeah all right cool what's your date of
birth
what time were you born yeah guys wrap
it up he did it
he did it because that's that's that's
pisces straight
right there oh that's cancer right there
yeah
yeah you did it prejudice is prejudice
and right now we're using it the most
extreme form example which is crime
but even in your dating life in your
work life you know if you really have
these ideas in the back your head and
they're like even affecting you
subconsciously
maybe it affects your potential dating
partners maybe it affects your
interactions
with your employees or your employer um
and that's why i say it's pretty
judicial i've seen so much [ __ ] that i
can't explain bro but life is like
so much deeper than we think it is you
know but like the human brain can only
conceptualize so much things because we
are only humans i'm telling you like
everything is literally vibration and we
we can't understand that as humans you
know um we derive really from aliens you
know like aliens and ufos like i'm
telling you bro like from the bottom of
my heart bro
like that [ __ ] is so real you know okay
you know like you brought up
i'm going to say this bro how old are
you i'm 18.
from when you were 10 to when you were
do you feel like you understand the
world a bit better from 10 to 18.
yeah but the world is literally still
the same though in the sense you know
yeah yeah right is it not possible
that your understanding is coming from
experience and learning
isn't it possible that yeah isn't it i'm
just gonna finish
is it possible that the things that we
don't understand is not due to some
necessarily cosmic force
but our inability to understand all the
variables involved in the things around
us
yes i agree with that as well you know
but the cosmic force is what controls
everything
like i promise you like bro you're under
you're under spiritual control like
literally at all times of the day you
you know like you only have what you
have because you're supposed to bro
watch my face
bro i can't watch your face no the what
40 and 45 seconds
this [ __ ] said god vibration
human brain aliens
cosmic control bro bro
watch my wash my face have that at the
time that you're supposed to have
you know god doesn't give you anything
too late or like too early when i say
god i'm not talking about like a
christian god or anything i'm talking
about the whole universe you know
um like it's always controlling you and
always like helping you at all times you
know
and like like when i say aliens and
stuff like that doesn't mean like oh let
like these aliens want to take over the
world they literally are here to help
you know
humankind you know today society is so
[ __ ] terrible you
you make videos about it you know like
bro like why are people so like
like unhappy and everything it's because
of social media you know like
they put these things in our lives you
know to control us you know make us
unhappy you know and like
that [ __ ] is like astrology is not like
prejudice towards you know like saying
like
this will determine your personality and
stuff like some people overblow it
you know like you know those girls who
like just talk about you know
astrologies like
to to say that oh you know this is my
personality like no
you know like you have to you actually
have an actual personality you know
behind you know
what is really like a you know different
from a child
[ __ ] bro you know but like bro life is
interesting bro i'm like
what's so [ __ ] funny bro like
i mean [ __ ] gonna laugh you know you
know it's fine
i'm sorry i can't i'm crying
you know and you know
humanity just has to change you know
that's little yeah
oh no like humanity just has to change
you know
good you know there's change coming you
know so
yeah [ __ ] is crazy though bro all right
brother man i appreciate you growing up
thank you
you have a good one bro
this [ __ ]
i'm sorry i just you ever have answers
go ahead the first thing you the first
thing is
if you if you talk to me the number of
like per seconds is astonishing
i haven't like it's good like you know
like you know
like this thing like and then like you
know like
it takes me off the context of the thing
then this guy
said everything and nothing at the same
time
it was a simple disagreement it was
simple
disagree with the fact that astrology
is prejudice but you know god and the
vibration
and you know human beings and the human
brain and the vibration
and the aliens are here to help us not
out not that come here to conquer us but
like you said everything and nothing
focus
and i'm not even saying that he was
wrong or anything like that he can't be
wrong
he can't be wrong because he didn't
really say anything
the reason why i was doing that is
because i was trying to be respectful
and not laugh
and the more the more you stop from
laughing the worse it got that's what
that's what happened
oh my god i should have tried to hold it
in
i shouldn't try to hold it in oh i was
trying bro i swear to god i was trying
that's why i had to look down i didn't
want him to see because i wanted him to
get a chance but
everyone could tell in the chat the chat
was dying the chat was like i have a
look up come on evan look up i'm like i
can't
all right i gotta i got a different clip
for you this [ __ ] oh my god that's good
thanks for that and then if you go into
a relationship
with that in the back of your mind
you're gonna
you you might affect the whole thing
because you you're gonna see
things that you want to see because
you're already prone to seeing them
because you already set yourself to see
that
yep so uh watch out
watch out that's not this ain't it to me
it ain't it people will say stuff oh
like i've met seven pisces and they had
a lot of similar personality traits
or you got confirmation bias you
probably have met hundreds of pisces
but the ones that stood out to you or
exhibited certain behaviors you asked
them what their sign was
and then it just confirmed an idea you
already had in your mind
right so we we fall into this logic a
lot of the times this kind of bad
confirmation by square
it's just one of those things like do i
really care that much about astrology no
i was just making the argument that it's
prejudicial and people
got really upset about it but that is
why people
people really follow it and it's it's
funny to me because
i read something that an article that
was saying that
it's really a trend thing and if you
look at
chinese astrology where a lot of these
things
are from and they take a lot of you know
they think a lot people think a lot of
people are following
astrology and stuff like that a lot of
these things are from china
right yeah and if you ask a chinese
person
what sign you are they're not going to
tell you monkey they're not going to
tell you
rat or [ __ ] they're not going to tell
you none of that they're actually
because of because it's more
the way the western astrology is made
it's more fun
they're going to believe more in western
astrology just because it's a trend
just because it's more the way it's done
the soap opera is more interesting
even them they don't even follow their
more astrology they follow the western
one and when you ask them why it's just
because there's more
patterns and stuff like that but it's
just it's
it's one a it is a trend but also
it it's not based on the thing it's
really just fun facts
it's very vague you know if you read
something like uh
whenever you um you read about cold
reading you know when people that it
can tell uh oh you know those people
that say that they're mediums and they
say that they can see in the future
sometimes they ask you questions that
are really it's a technique it's a
technique called cold reading
cold reading i'm able to make vague
questions
and you're going to answer them for me
and i'm going to use them to further
more
my research is going to make me look
like i know
you or can tell into the future there
are techniques about that and stuff like
that
again it's not a scheme but it's just
something that is not necessarily true
they're not they're using all these
techniques
magicians use to make their shows
and it makes it look like it's really
really fortune tellers tarot readers
all of that cold reading cold reading
they're using it's funny you brought
that up let me
let me do something hello hey
is that a mandela behind you yeah
all right guys guys i'm already telling
you right now it's gonna be a good chat
this girl is into astrology let's go
do you have any plants around you
where's your nearest place yes they do
okay
okay and can i ask you um is there one
of your parents
do you have one parent that you don't
really get along with at all
yeah yeah yeah i feel you let's not go
there do you have a strong connection to
animals
yes that's very vague isn't it
most people have plants most people have
animals and have a strong connection
it's a 50 50 chance and most people
have a preference for one of their
parents they're close to one parent and
knuckles in a
cold reading that's all it is abba's not
a genius yes he is but
i don't think there's too many people i
don't have a strong connection to
animals at all i really don't care about
them
i eat them and i don't mind
well um listen i i'm pretty sure now
you're at a place where you want your
own space and
you want to be able to cultivate i have
my own space now
yeah yeah because you can't do it like
you need to just be able to preserve
your energy and kind of just keep
a lot of that outside noise out a little
bit right
and how do you feel like astrology's
helped you with your dating prospects
it hasn't
so i had to put in that last clip
oh that's funny it hasn't that's right
no it hasn't
i just have to put in that last clip um
but yeah that was just
and there is a big difference between
saying
we can observe americans in american
trends in american cultural norms and
say
this is generally true for this
population and there's a huge difference
between you saying
you're born on this day the moon was in
this position therefore this is your
personality
there have been no recorded
studies to back those ideas up if i say
americans are obese
as a cultural norm right that's a
generalization well we have studies to
back that up
you understand it's a bit different yeah
and americans can literally
back that asset because they have plenty
of it shout out juvenile
just be careful guys just don't
understand like generalizations aren't
inherently bad but when you really
believe in them
and when you think that they're sensible
sometimes you end up in really bad
bad thought patterns just be mindful of
that so
that's all anything else you want to add
oh my god you must have slept well that
night because
of all that laughter and oh the people
the people and it's really when you tap
onto something that i really believe
like spirituality and stuff like that
and you challenge that people get really
like oh no let's look at things let's
look at facts
people don't want to look at facts of
the things that they really like like
their spirituality yeah yeah it's not a
relation
it's not a religion but it's pretty
close if you guys enjoyed today's video
leave a like comment if you disagree let
us know why
and that's it for today's video if you
guys want to see the full live with
every other guest that i had talking
about astrology you guys can find that
on patreon
[Music]
ah
uh
[Music]